Speaker 1: Let's go.
Let's go over to the UK and talk to George
from the UK.
George, where in the UK are you?
Speaker 4: George.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Hi, there.
Yeah, I'm from just outside of London, about
an hour away from London to the West.
Beautiful, although not the most glamorous
town, but are still pretty good.
That's good.
Um, I have a question about COVID restrictions,
especially in the post vaccine world.
Yeah.
So countries like the UK and Australia, what
we've done is once the majority of the population
is vaccinated, especially older people.
Yes, we've kind of had to let it rip approach.
And obviously, it's very different in the
US because of the kind of political situation
and the decentralized system there.
But here in the UK, yeah, a bit of a let let
it rip approach.
And I'm not the biggest fan of Boris Johnson.
There's lots of things to criticize him for,
but I think this is one thing that he's got
right.
In the case where you put your faith in the
vaccines and then you, yeah, you open up the
economy and you basically let the virus do
its thing.
And I think my my understanding is on balance
when you balance health, economy, et cetera,
I think that's the right thing.
Did you but did you have an opinion on this
approach?
Do you think it's better to be more cautious
or kind of just let things happen?
Speaker 1: The answer is different depending
on what is happening.
At the time, there was a moment where the
vaccines were very good at preventing people
from getting sick at all.
But now we have a situation where the vaccines
are better at preventing people from getting
seriously ill and dying on average.
Remember on average, and the virus is now
so transmissible that there really is no containing
it.
So I think the right approach changes as the
circumstances on the ground change.
Now, as far as the UK moving in the direction
of removing all COVID restrictions, including
masking, which remind me, is it in 60 days
that that's happening or when is that happening?
Speaker 4: That is now happening in about
Speaker 1: days, in about 10 days.
OK.
When it comes to that, when you look at, you
know, you guys are ahead of the U.S. in terms
of the immigrant wave, you're already well
on the decline.
If you believe that at this point it is becoming
endemic, that Macron has burned through the
population and at least until next flu season,
things are going to be well controlled.
It doesn't seem crazy to me to say, Listen,
the vaccines have been available for a year.
We have a less severe but very contagious
variant, which is still more serious than
a cold, but much less serious than the previous
ones.
If we can keep the medical system from being
overwhelmed while removing restrictions at
a certain point, I understand that countries
are going to do it and it doesn't seem crazy
now if in the fall there's a much more deadly
variant.
And there's a different situation, my opinion
might change, but the numbers point to me
understanding why the U.K. is doing what it's
doing now.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I agree, and I think it's
a good gamble politically as well, because
you have all these, you know, the opposition
last year in the face of the Delta Wave, we
didn't really do too much and then on the
ground, we didn't do, you know, we changed
hardly anything as well.
Yes.
And you have now, you know, the opposition
was calling for more restrictions, further
lockdowns and things like that.
And now the conservative government can turn
around and say, you know, we did in lockdown,
we saved the economy and we kept, yeah, we
kept the country open.
Yes.
You know, it's a it's a good thing politically
as well as hopefully health wise as well as
Speaker 1: long as it doesn't backfire.
Yeah.
Hey, listen, I'm curious.
You know how there's all these clever pub
names in the UK?
You know, you've got like the spotted pig
and the her paddock frog and all these different
things.
Is there a particularly clever pub name in
your town?
Speaker 4: Not really, like Swindon is very
known for its like railway history, so there's
lots of railway named Pub The Steam in and
things like that.
Got nothing to kind of cheeky.
In Swindon, it's a bit too boring for that.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, we'll see if we can get something opened
up there, hopefully.
Very good.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
I appreciate it.
Thanks, David.
All right.
Wow.
The George from the UK.
What a beautiful phone call.
Why don't we go next to let's go to Is it
Nathan from Green Acres, Florida?
Speaker 2: Hello.
Hello, David, how are you doing?
Speaker 1: Where is Green Acres?
Speaker 2: Green Acres?
Florida is in Palm Beach County.
Oh, between Wellington and Lake Worth.
Speaker 1: Also, it's sort of like Trump Country,
right?
Speaker 2: I could drive to Trump to Trump's
Mar a Lago.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
OK.
Speaker 1: All right.
That's interesting.
Well, what's on your mind?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so.
Hello.
I've been watching your show for years.
It's a privilege to speak with you.
The privilege is mine.
I am Nathan.
I am in the city of Green Acres.
I'm a candidate for city council.
But recently there's been some drama, which
I think relates to national politics in a
way.
OK, so we know that the right wing is going
hard on the cancel culture narrative.
They think they're being censored.
They think they're being canceled.
Anybody with like two brain cells knows that.
That's nonsense.
You know, social media is constantly questioning
like Shapiro and all that stuff.
But recently, in a City Council meeting, the
mayor, who happens to be a Democrat, was censored
by three members who two Republicans and one
Democrat.
But I hear it's like a Democrat in name only.
And I just wanted to share that because it's
interesting he wanted to dispel, excuse me.
Oh my God.
He wanted to dispel a rumor.
And they adjourned the meeting.
And the footage is on the mayor's Facebook
page recorded by an amazing member of the
community and the crowd.
I wonder who that is.
OK.
And yeah, you know, I meant, are you are
Speaker 1: originally from Florida?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Whole life lived.
That's interesting, because
Speaker 1: I don't want to get off the substance,
but the word that I say, Mayor, you say mayor
almost like a horse, you know, a female horse
maker.
Is that a local thing there?
Speaker 2: I I'm not sure, I always say, mayor,
never.
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
Well, listen, it all sounds like more of the
same, you know, they claim the other side
is doing that, which they do, and it's projection
and we're used to it at this point, you know?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
Yeah.
Hopefully, you know, I get in and I we don't
have that censorship and it's a bit more stability
in the council.
But until then, those three have the majority
because the way the system is, there is the
mayor, the deputy mayor, who's a council member,
a council member and then the three others.
The mayor has no voting power, so those three
have a voting bloc and they're able to essentially
censors stop progress, whatever they want
to do.
Yes, and right now, all three of them are
being challenged, including by myself.
And it's shaping up to be an interesting race.
Now, I wish the media would pay a little bit
more attention to, but.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, Nathan, giving us the inside scoop on
the politics of Green Acres Florida.
Nathan, I appreciate hearing from you and
we're going to do our best to keep an eye
on on all of it.
Quite frankly, we are going to follow all
of it.